cette bataille de kiev qui seraient en
cours bruno daroux je me tourne vers
vous vladimir poutine qui serait prêt à
envoyer une délégation à minsk en
biélorussie pour des pourparlers avec
l'ukraine tout ça c'est encore ce n'est
pas confirmé est ce que cela pourrait
être envisageable de parler entre les
ukrainiens et les russes oui ça pourrait
être envisageable parce que vladimir
poutine a toujours continué à dire qu'il
était prêt à négocier mais le problème
c'est qu'il est prêt à négocier à ces
conditions et que ces conditions ne sont
pas négociables donc évidemment ça
devient tout de suite très compliqué
c'est ce qui s'est passé un peu dans
tous leurs armes diplomatiques auxquels
on a assisté ces dernières semaines vous
l'a dit mir pauline a toujours dit et
son ministre lavrov sont aujourd'hui
mais nous nous sommes pour la diplomatie
nous sommes pour la discussion mais nous
avons des propositions alors voilà nos
propositions seulement c'est un peu
elles sont à prendre ou à laisser donc
évidemment à partir de ce moment là la
discussion devient complexe donc oui si
la nuire poutine en tout cas propose ça
ça veut dire quand même qu'il est
conscient qu'il ne faut pas qu'il
s'isole trop de la communauté
internationale mais ç'a toujours été son
objectif de même qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
ne voulaient pas se s'isoler se couper
de la communauté économique
internationale là il se rend compte
quand même malgré tout même si les
sanctions soit insuffisante etc il se
rend compte que la russie est un peu en
train de devenir le parent il ya en
quelque sorte de l'ordre international
et que donc il faut continuer à envoyer
des signaux comme quoi on est prêts à
discuter mais de quoi comme vous dites
il veut imposer ses conditions
finalement donc qu'est-ce que c'est ces
conditions c'est remplacer le pouvoir à
kiev en faire un faire de l'ukraine un
vassal de la russie alors maintenant
c'est un peu ça
alors avant c'était mieux mais c'est lié
bien sûr c'était avoir la garantie
écrite que l'ukraine allait jamais
adhéré à l'otan à voir aussi un
désarmement si on comprend bien des pays
frontaliers de l'otan revenir à la
situation de 1997